[Applause]
so we're using wearables as a
jumping-off point to think about the
intersections of the body and Technology
and the intersections of art and science
I'm trained originally as a biologist I
did a PhD empathetic biology in a small
school down the river and today I work a
lot with artists and designers to think
about the way that social emotional and
aesthetic parts of science are part of
culture and as we listen I work at
ginkgo Bioworks down at the Seaport
we're organism design company and I
think about the ways that we imagine
design and communicate new biological
technologies I'm a science fiction
artist I'm trained in French classical
ballet and interior design and I use
science fiction as a as a mechanism for
prototyping the future and I'm really
interested in how we might evolve and as
Lila mentioned exploring the body in
extreme environments so I love working
with artists like Lucy because I think
for me as a scientist being able to
collaborate with artists bring such a
different perspective on things I think
that artists are really open leave
themselves really vulnerable and are
really willing to take risks to jump
into the unknown for the sake of
curiosity without having an ultimate
conclusion in mind I'm really willing to
take that path you have been exploring
the different mindsets of the artist
versus the entrepreneur and we talked
about perhaps how science takes risk to
discover to find truth and to
problem-solve and the very definition of
taking risk is to be open to danger and
exchange familiarity and comfort for
uncertainty so yeah we share this this
wish or future of technology that its
fleshy its visceral it's messy its
elastic and it has feeling so when when
Lila invited us to think about wearables
on this panel we started by just
corresponding I live here in Boston Lucy
lives in Melbourne Australia so we had a
hard time finding a time to talk on the
phone so we were just sending each other
emails with questions at the beginning
so I started with these really boring
questions - Lucy you know what are
wearables what are they for
and and what will they enable and when
when Christina sent me those questions I
was really disappointed I shot a laptop
and sort of walked away and thought okay
I'll deal with it later and I think
that's partly to do with the work that
I'm doing now I'm really interested in
the body in extreme environments and
also I was part of the team at Philips
probes back in 2006 we prototyped
this emotional sensing dress and there I
worked with engineers and fashion
designers and we were trying to explore
emotional sensing and try to understand
what was happening to the body when you
kiss someone for the first time or when
you brush past a stranger and could we
make technology that blushed or shivered
so those two words when they're together
wearable and technology really didn't
resonate with me and and I really agree
with what her saying talked about you
know these sensual prototypes moving
into the business world and that's a
massive challenge so we were interested
in these stereotypes and trying to break
down you know the gadgets called the
clinical and the lack of sensuality so
during the evenings whilst at Philips I
began experimenting with a textile
designer by Tess and we were working in
very immediate low-tech ways using
washing up liquid and water with a cake
blender and imagining how the body might
change we were you know having these
very high-tech conversations at Philips
but we're interested in using the skin
as an accessory and could the body
replicate nature and that sense of
vulnerability in the experiments was was
really clear we were coming from a very
primal and intuitive way
with no idea of what the the image would
end up in the end so even before Lucy
ended up dealing with these questions
and answering them I was also really
bored I thinking about it and I'm
pregnant now and I'm also thinking a lot
about the body and Technology in
different ways because there are all
these ways that technology used to
monitor and surveil and watch out for
the body that's pregnant and there's
also this meme about the uterus being an
on board 3d printer and so I kind of
like this idea like is this you know is
the uterus leave wearable technology so
I shot over another email to Lucy saying
well you know are you interested in this
and and you'd like to add to bring it
into the world and the kinds of
questions that I think that Lucy asks
what would the midwife's clinic look
like in ten thousand years so naturally
I got really excited because I've been
thinking about writing a TV show about
the future of procreation and the body
beyond its edge what if you're born from
a petri dish and how might this changed
the phenomenon of touch so so our emails
got a little wacky ER and crazier are we
started talking about women who had
given birth while they were in comas
artificial intelligence the future
affects beauty and attraction and all of
this had definitely feminist themes and
overtones and certainly our work is very
feminist and I love how Lucy's work is
really about dousing technology in
feminine themes and feminine aesthetics
and by changing the aesthetic really
challenging the stereotypes and the
expectations of what it is that
technology is what can technology can do
and so you know in thinking about like
well what is the feminist wearable maybe
that's a place to start so I googled it
and it was really disappointing so it's
all like t-shirts that have like
feminist slogans or jewelry that also
has like girl power are kind of slogans
on it so this really inspired us to
start thinking well okay what is geminus
technology can we start asking that
question and breaking down some of those
barriers
so to change that stereotype of what a
wearable is or what technology is and
what it can do I think we first have to
start to rethink of what is the purpose
of these kinds of technologies I love
this project this is by some of the
students my students at Art Center when
I was teaching out in Pasadena so
Christina Ortega and Jenny Roden house
had this project on useless wearables
asking you know if what's the future of
the nail salon incorporating some of
these technologies into into the nails
yeah and I think we also we want to
rethink what counts as technology in the
first place what are we already wearing
you know is our cosmetics of wearable
technology is perfume of wearable
technology and then what's already part
of our bodies what can we harvest in the
technological way and can the microbiome
be a platform for wearable technology so
the microbes that live on your skin that
are part of our bodies and our
ecosystems is that something that we can
alter through our experiences or through
technology in a way that is wearable and
with technology so we'd started at a
wearable and then had gone to birth from
petri dishes so we decided to present
three different scales that go from
inside of the body all the way out to
space and sort of challenge and manifest
this concept around sensual technology
so here we consider the skin and the
microbiome as a wearable technology and
the skin as a platform for technology
and how this may affect the health
beauty the scent and how we communicate
so after working at Philips I became
really interested in how we can
reprogram the body and how that may
become a technology so I worked with a
synthetic biologist and created a
swallowable perfume which is a cosmetic
pill that works from the inside out and
when you sweat you sweat a biologically
enhanced fragrance and what I like is
that it turns the body into the atomizer
and you become the spray and then I
started to think about what if you could
impregnate that with color and you could
at cosmetics and and really disrupt the
beauty market which we both agree needs
some massive disruption so part of this
project I'm also a filmmaker was to use
the gallery as a lab and as a place to
prototype these ideas and I'm really
interested in exploring the scientific
what if within the public realm and
using stories to communicate science
that that we can reach the fringes of
culture and then really explore the
emotional impact of technology and
create is platform to discuss how some
of these scientific breakthrough the
slowly redesigning our body this is
another artwork that questions that
point where technology meets the body
this film is called makes your maker and
it looks at how food and the body are
inseparable and you see this woman in
her lab cloning her body to the point of
photosynthesis I'm massively inspired by
the extremes of genetic engineering and
to the point where synthetic biology may
reach the kitchen and so we're in the
kitchen blending gender and ego like a
chef may make a take and to the point
where you make these edible clones in
order to eat yourself to enhance your
senses in the way you experience the
world and I agree it's slightly absurd
but I think it's you know absurdity that
needs to step in into this conversation
around science and technology so it's
not that absurd because I didn't I did
try to make photosynthetic animals in
graduate school okay
and I did I as we mentioned I did do
this project about cheese and the
intersections between cheese and the
microbes and cheese and the microbes on
the body
the collaboration was to fill Toula to
the smell researcher and and we really
wanted to think about the domestication
of microbes
how we bring microbes into our lives
already the the technologies of
transformation that happen with microbes
something as traditional and everyday as
cheese and also this intersection
between ourselves and our food so we are
what we eat
the bacteria that live in cheese are
quite similar to the bacteria that live
on skin and the smells of skin body
odors are pretty similar to cheese
smelly probably smells pretty stinky
cheese that smells like sheep that's
because it's the same kind of bacteria
and so this isn't this is actually a
microbial portrait this is so we did one
with Ola fertilizing Spears
this is Hans Ulrich Obrist is nose
bacteria turns into a sheep a lot of the
work that I do with skinca as still as
bringing in works with with artists
collaborations with artists like Lucy
and this all again but working within
the context of the fragrance industry so
thinking about what would the swallow
bowl perfume smell like working with
perfumers and collaborating to create
those smells and then working with sisal
to imagine a future of the fragrance
industry where it's the microbes that
live on our skin that make perfume and
not chemical companies so as we kind of
zoom out slightly and start think going
from the the microbes and the skin
itself to the second skin the body and
the kinds of technologies that we put
onto the body and we wanted to think
again how we can challenge the
stereotypes of the wearables the
wearables the technology and its purpose
at the body surface so instead of now
moving towards this idea of intimate
technology
what's technology that's soft emotional
fleshy elastic what helps us be more
empathetic something that connects us
rather than measures us or monitors us
so I want to show some again student
work from students I had in a class that
where we did design for the microbiome
at Art Center so this project was
looking at creating this modular jewelry
based around microbes that coulda
capsulate a moment in time and
motion I'm so I can't remember her name
Jihan she was a she wanted to kind of be
able to kind of embed these memories and
emotions in these petri dishes so she
would whisper the story on to it or
kiss-kiss the petri dish or if she was
having an emotional moment and cry put
the tears on to the aunt of addition it
would grow the emotions into these sort
of lasting memories that she could embed
in this jewelry and kind of mix and
match into a modular a modular object
this project bye-bye show Chen yang she
was interested in this idea that people
who live together share elements of
their microbiome that you kind of fuse
together this exterior microbial cloud
of yourself and so she was wondering
what happens to couples that live apart
it are they missing something that keeps
them together some form of intimacy
through the microbes and can you kind of
create an object that couples living
apart could exchange via the male to
bring those microbes bring them microbes
more in sync so that's the pro bio pet
concept this is the future day spa which
was originally designed to prepare the
body for space travel and when it show a
demo video so it's a personalized guided
experience that offers treatments that
are both states of trust love and
relaxation and essentially it replicates
the feeling of being hugged I originally
did this at the London Design Festival
and then we took it to Los Angeles to
the recode conference and we've treated
over a hundred clients some came back
the next day saying it got rid of my
hangover others said it felt like being
back inside the room and this again was
prototyping during the experience and
the last day you know in Los Angeles one
client as he lay very vulnerably and
that was part of it I'm really
interested in creating vulnerable
experiences to shift behavior and as he
lay down in the bed he disclosed to me
that he suffered haptter phobia this
fear of
being touched and that he doesn't touch
any other body and nobody touched him
and he was clearly moved he said this
felt like an embrace and he asked if he
could buy one and take one home with him
so I gave him an extra-long treatment
and then when he got up out of the bed
he reached out and he hugged me so this
was a very unexpected response and it's
made me speculate whether these new
kinds of isolation could be developed to
treat social isolation or some spectrums
of autism and I'm really interested in
creating experiences that can take
people beyond the expectations of
themselves so moving out in our our
sliding scale I don't know if people
have seen lo and behold Verna Herzl
documentary Danny Hillis is an inventor
amongst other things and he said we are
having a revolution in what it means to
be human and this is a question that
really gets me going I get very excited
about these kinds of questions wondering
what is you know what is human evolution
the future of human evolution look like
and how all different points of view
shaped this question so this question of
how what are the possible revolutions
that will happen to the body it's really
interesting where where will bodies and
technologies meet in the far future what
is the future of the body on a changing
planet and an extreme new environment
like outer space will the body change
through technological transformation
through redesign new conditioning or
even editing within this question again
there's lots of different scales and
lots of ways that you can imagine the
way that the body might be transformed
through a molecular at a molecular level
in the genome or the cellular processes
inside of a cell there's a lot of ways
that scientists are starting to think
about how we would transform ourselves
at a genetic level there's also the ways
that we are born and give birth and
imagining the future of what that might
look like through technological
interventions
so if we are going to live longer in
environments that our bodies are not
designed for we may need to evolve in
really unusual ways and how do we begin
to fathom what life will be like 100
generations from now or 500 generations
from now and maybe I'm just going to
bring back this slide I know if you can
see but this is a device to give birth
in in my crew sorry zero gravity so it's
a centrifugal platform that spins around
and you give birth and this is a
Japanese scientist who has created this
extra EXO womb where she's bringing to
birth goats so we've looked at
discussing the body and changing it
through genetics and this next project
which is being shown downstairs is
exploring how we can adapt the body
through experience that go beyond kind
of genetic traits and after the results
of the future days became really
interested in the psychology of
isolation and so this project is called
the Institute of isolation it's a nine
and a half minute observational
fictional documentary it's a futuristic
organization that contemplates weather
isolation or more broadly speaking
extreme experience could be used to
condition or optimize the body and it
explores this idea of us being able to
train our bodies now for the rigors of
weightlessness in the future and how
that might improve life or our health on
earth so also I'm interested in ways of
yeah conditioning our bodies now in the
kind of evolution of exercise Pilates
yoga step Reebok this is a microgravity
trainer that we built so the Institute
of isolation and then thinking about
what would a wearable be in space beyond
the astronaut suit and is the whole ship
a wearable because that's allowing us to
to function and to live in this vacuum
of space
so I love that and I love working with
artists going I said before because of
this new and different vision that they
can bring to the future I think that
when we do start to imagine the future
and talk about how science and
technology are going to impact that
future especially a place like MIT that
that vision is really monopolized by
scientists and engineers themselves by
the science and technology and the
aesthetic and the imagination that they
bring to it so I think that it's
necessary for us to have a multiplicity
of vision and a way of multiplicity of
ways of thinking about what that future
is going to look like and and not let
people who have control over what it
might look like imagined it to so I
think that projects like like Lucy's and
other intersections of art and science
help us imagine a future that is more
fleshy and feminine that has is more
intuitive and emotional that's grounded
in storytelling a narrative and maybe
offers a little bit more messiness and
more reality of what it's like to live
in these kinds of futures yes so another
important thing that we're really
interested in is that the development of
science and technology being really
transparent and accessible to everyone
which allows more diversity and gives
access for artists to collaborate
directly with scientists biologists and
creating this platform to discuss what
are the cultural implications of
emerging technologies and and how can we
reach those far-flung fringes of culture
and have them feedback on this opinion
and when science and art meets it can
become more tangible and kind of
physical eise's things that maybe
otherwise incomprehensible so the last
point that we want to leave you guys
with is thinking about where the
creative process should be part of
science I think when we think about the
role of art and science often we're left
thinking about communication the sort of
the final step of science technology
when it leaves the lab and is
communicated so the outside
the world that's the role of the artist
is to make it presentable where in fact
I think we see a role for science
after art really at the very beginning
of the creative the creative process of
science and the process of innovation
that creative process is a process of
asking new and difficult questions that
go beyond what science would would be
able to do perhaps and and perhaps that
because of the kind of vulnerability and
emotional intuition and a willingness to
leave that subjectivity in whereas I
think scientists want to remove it from
the story that we tell at the end so
just to wrap up we are living in this
era where we're being constantly asked
to reshuffle and redefine human
boundaries and this creative process is
a way to present conditions of
possibility so we're ending in some more
questions that maybe we can talk about
is CRISPR a wearable technology do we
become technology when our genes have
been edited and when when the body does
meet technology does the body then
become technology itself
you